Rimbaud entre chez le vieil homme armé
d'une barre de fer il l'aurait frappé à
mort avec un couteau il aurait prélevé
la langue et le cœur de sa victime avant
de les cuire avec des haricots Jérémy
Rimbaud aurait ensuite mis le feu au
corps avant de s'enfuir mais sa cavale
n'est pas fini
au pied des Pyrénées nouillons un petit
village de 200 habitants
[Musique]
Jean Duval est le maire de la commune il
est encore traumatisé par ce qui s'est
passé le 14 novembre dernier
salut cette nuit là le maire a dû
reconnaître le corps d'un des habitants
du village
assassiné et affreusement mutilé
j'ai vu quelque chose que je ne souhaite
à personne de voir vu l'état comment il
avait été massacré ça vous marque ça
vous flash ça vous et c'est des choses
que je pense que j'aurai un moment un
bon moment à mettre à évacuer
le maire n'ose même plus s'approcher de
la maison où le meurtre a eu lieu là on
la voit à la Maison de la voilà c'est
par là voilà
c'est ici que Léopold PDO a été
assassiné dans sa propre maison
l'agriculteur de 90 ans que tout le
monde appelait popol a été tué à coup de
barres de fer son meurtrier l'a ensuite
découpé avant d'essayer de le manger
Jésus jaudra était l'un de ses amis
c'était un gars formidable il est en
pleine santé il a mis la santé moi je
rechauffe le type là je crois que je
sais pas ce que je refais là
on s'est calmé bien entendu mais c'est
les affreux le gars il a pris une barre
de fer il a assommé il a mangé la langue
il a sorti le cœur et il s'est cuisiné
tout ça on rendait compte vous rendez
compte ce que ça fait c'est c'est
affreux
la victime de ce meurtre barbares a été
enterré ici le 25 novembre dernier
celui qui est soupçonné d'avoir commis
ce crime s'appelle Jérémy Rimbaud il est
âgé de 26 ans c'est un enfant du pays
engagé dans l'armée de terre il y a 5
ans il venait de quitter son régiment
cet ancien soldat a fait l'Afghanistan
comment expliquer un tel acte de
cannibalisme pourquoi aurait-il commis
ce crime trois semaines seulement après
avoir quitté l'armée
portrait d'un jeune homme d'apparence
normal qui aurait commis l'impensable
pour savoir qui est Jérémy Rimbaud nous
avons rencontré Marie son ex petit ami
elle témoigne pour la première fois
Marie vivait avec le jeune homme depuis
qu'il avait quitté l'armée en octobre
l'été dernier le couple était parti en
vacances
sur ses photos souvenir d'un temps
heureux Jérémy avait l'air d'aller bien
voilà il était tout à fait normal
ça lui faisait du bien quoi ça se voyait
que il était il était heureux quoi il se
passait bien
donc là quand on voit les photos on
n'imagine pas qu'il est en dépression
non
pourtant tout aurait basculé trois mois
après ses vacances
le matin du 12 novembre deux jours avant
le meurtre Marie était témoin des
premiers délires de germes
la jambe qui tremblait il était vraiment
il était vraiment mal quoi ça se voyait
qu'il avait qu'il avait pas dormi et
qu'il était pas qu'il était pas maître
de lui-même quoi là il était il était
complètement une autre personne il
cherchait qu'une chose c'était de me
convaincre que c'était la fin du monde
donc qui arrivait le 1er décembre
c'était vraiment le jour où voilà il
fallait vraiment fuir les flammes de
l'enfer sur le monde qu'on allait
s'envoler comme des oiseaux et tout ça
enfin c'était vraiment le délire total
quoi donc là c'est comme si on avait
pris possession de lui quoi quand
vraiment on dit être possédé mais c'est
ça il était possédé quoi
le lendemain de cette crise le mercredi
13 novembre Jérémy Raimbaud débute une
errance de 24 Heures qui aurait abouti
au meurtre
nous avons reconstitué son itinéraire
il prend la direction du nord et suite
un tracé parfaitement rectiligne
Jérémy Rimbault part de momère il va
passer par Tarbes bazette
Vic-en-Bigorre avant d'arriver 30 km
plus loin à New York
première étape momère le village de son
enfance
Jérémy Rimbaud quitte le domicile de sa
mère sans ses papiers
il serait toujours en proie des délires
comme l'explique le journaliste Andy
barréjeau qui a couvert toute l'affaire
pour la Nouvelle République des Pyrénées
il aurait vu chez lui un livret un
livret classique de sudoku de le jeu
donc le jeu le jeu d'origine asiatique
et par une interprétation on aurait
déduit que il fallait qu'il laisse le
sud au cul donc derrière littéralement
le sud derrière lui donc c'est pour ça
qu'il a pris la direction du nord
Jérémy poursuit sa route vers Tarbes où
il aurait été aperçu en centre-ville
le lendemain jeudi 14 novembre le matin
du meurtre il atteint le village de
Basècles
là il sonne chez des habitants qu'il
accueillent par hospitalité pendant
quelques heures
[Musique]
nous avons retrouvé le couple qu'il a
hébergé ils acceptent de nous répondre
en restant anonyme car ils ne veulent
pas être associés à ce drame il est venu
tout droit là il est rentré ici on s'est
engagé tous les deux ici
voilà
il est venu là et il s'est assis là
à peu près deux heures pendant que ses
affaires se laver à la machine à laver
et qu'elle se séchent sèche pendant deux
heures de temps on est resté là je vous
dis il était à l'aise avec moi il était
cohérent jamais il a aussi l'auto et
jamais il a plaisanté il a rigolé
dans cette maison Jérémy prend un petit
déjeuner et d'or une demi-heure l'homme
qui l'accueille ne détecte rien
d'anormal
ce qui leur fait là-bas c'est pas
possible moi ces deux êtres tout à fait
différents ce qu'il a été ici il y a
rien à lui reprocher rien strictement
rien c'est un être comme les autres là à
ce moment-là je me dis que je suis passé
à côté on est passé à côté d'un truc
vraiment lourd mais bon c'était pas mon
heure si vous voulez
Jérémy Rimbaud se remettant route
apparemment calme mais quelques heures
plus tard son comportement a changé à
vie qu'on Bigorre il serait entré
visiblement stressé dans une librairie
il nous a demandé de rencontrer un
psychologue voilà il voulait consulter
un psychologue en urgence on a trouvé on
a trouvé ça effectivement très étrange
on était cinq dans le magasin on a tous
regardé on trouve que quelqu'un vienne
nous faire cette cette requête
malgré son angoisse Jérémy Rimbaud
continue sa route vers le nord jusqu'à
New York sa dernière étape
nous sommes le jeudi 14 novembre il est
19h
[Musique]
c'est au bout de story que se trouve la
maison de Léopold pedebido qui a
simplement le malheur de regarder à
travers la fenêtre et qui croise donc le
regard de ce jeune homme
et à partir de là c'est là où commence
l'horreur
à la nuit tombée germir un beau entre
chez le vieil homme
armé d'une barre de fer il l'aurait
frappé à mort
l'horreur ne s'arrête pas là avec un
couteau il aurait prélevé la langue et
le cœur de sa victime avant de les cuire
avec des haricots il aurait ensuite
goûté et recracher sans avaler
Jérémy Rimbault aurait ensuite mis le
feu au corps avant de s'enfuir mais sa
cavale n'est pas finie
1 km plus loin près de ce silo à maïs il
agresse violemment un agriculteur sur
son tracteur
ce survivant a raconté cette attaque à
la radio RTL
l'individu est venu me taper en me
disant je vais te tuer je vais te tuer
je vais te tuer et moi j'ai eu le temps
de reprendre la barre de fer qu'il avait
je lui ai foutu un coup de barre de fer
dans les côtes et cet individu il n'a
pas bougé d'un millimètre c'était une
personne sur humaine le peu de temps que
j'ai pu le voir il a il avait les dames
bien serrées et il était déterminé
quelques heures plus tard les gendarmes
arrêtent Jérémy Rimbaud son errance est
terminée
comment expliquer ces pulsions
meurtrières
lors de son audition germir un beau
reconnaît le crime mais surtout il
déclare que des voix lui ont ordonné de
le commettre
c'est ce qui explique la procureur de
Tarbes dans une conférence de presse
donnez le lendemain du meurtre
pas ni dans la mesure où il a obéit à
des messages qui pour lui étaient des
messages d'origine supérieure et qui
donc lui commandait de faire cela mais
il savait effectivement ce qu'il faisait
les messages recommandés de faire
j'adire de son audition il a toujours su
qu'il l'avait enlever la vie à quelqu'un
qui est vraiment Jérémy Rimbaud quel
homme se cache derrière le masque du
tueur cannibale
son enfance dans le village de momer au
pied des Pyrénées sa mère est secrétaire
son père travaille dans l'industrie
aéronautique
pendant son adolescence Jérémy joue au
foot sur ce stade Sébastien l'a connu à
cette époque il faisait partie de la
même équipe
donc voilà c'était une photo d'équipe il
y a un verront une douzaine d'années
donc voilà Jérémie est là que voilà de
très souriante on voit qu'il a une
histoire de vivre quoi
d'après Sébastien Jérémy n'était pas un
ado violent et moi je l'ai toujours
connu calme sur un terrain c'était plus
lui qui prenait les coups parce que
c'était quelqu'un de d'assez petit et il
restait toujours calme à chaque fois il
a jamais eu un sursaut d'humeur sur un
terrain de foot et c'était vraiment un
exemple un exemple sur un terrain quoi
il y avait il y avait vraiment jamais eu
un souci avec lui
un garçon apparemment tranquille
c'est ce que confirme Grégory un autre
ami de Jérémy qui la fréquenté plus tard
avant le départ à l'armée du jeune homme
[Musique]
peut connaître quelqu'un et quelqu'un
peut être normal alors normal ou
d'apparence normal j'en sais rien ça
peut pas savoir et du jour au lendemain
mais tout s'effondre en fait on peut
tous avoir en nous une faiblesse
psychologique qui fait qu'un jour
des goupilles sans raison
Jérémy Rimbaud avait-il une faille
psychologique un épisode de sa vie a
peut-être tout changé son séjour comme
soldat en Afghanistan à 21 ans il
s'engage au régiment d'infanterie des
chars de Marines de Poitiers bon soldat
il est promu caporal fin 2010 il est
envoyé en mission en Afghanistan
est-ce ici que tout aurait basculé
au cours de son séjour jérémyre Rimbault
assiste à des actions de combat
c'est ce que nous révèle Marie son ex
petit ami il lui a confié avoir échappé
à un attentat
donc lui conduisait son 4x4 là
il passait en convoi en fait et
au moment où lui il passe donc tout va
bien et au moment où ses collègues qui
le suivaient derrière
passent il y a une saute sur la mine en
fait il nous a fait comprendre en gros
qu'il avait vu ses collègues
brûlé devant lui quoi enfin c'est ça
en juin 2011 quand germir un beau
revient à sa caserne un médecin
militaire lui diagnostic un stress
post-traumatique une blessure
psychologique qui touche certains
soldats confrontés à la guerre il
bénéficie d'un suivi psychologique qui
pour ses proches ne suffit pas à
atténuer ses souffrances il m'a dit je
honnêtement je sais pas si j'ai bien
fait de de
m'engager à l'armée parce que il fait ça
m'a lui-même m'a dit ça m'a détruit
quelque part ça m'a détruit il était pas
assez fort pour affronter tout ça quoi
les supérieurs de germir Rimbaud
étaient-ils au courant de cette
fragilité nous nous sommes rendus au
quartier général de son régiment c'est
le petit matin lors du rassemblement
pour les soldats
Jérémy Rimbault servait ici il y a
encore quelques semaines comme
conducteur de blindés fin octobre ces
officiers lui avaient même proposé de
resigner un contrat de 5 ans mais il
avait préféré quitter l'armée nous ne
sommes pas autorisés à parler à ses
camarades c'est donc le commandant en
seconde du régiment Bruno bourseix qui
nous répond
c'était un
bon marsouin qui a
qui a donné toute satisfaction dans
pendant les 50 il a servi au régime rien
ne présageait nous dans nos à nos
connaissances à ce qu'il fasse des
choses pareilles les supérieurs de
Jérémy n'ont donc pas vu venir son coup
de folie aucun médecin militaire n'a
alerté le commandement du régime
[Musique]
le médecin qui juge ce qui doit être
rapporté au commandement ou pas alors
vous n'avez pas été alerté par un
médecin sur le cas j'ai un Mirabeau non
aucun médecin nous a dit nous a alerté
sur un sur un fait marquant sur le capot
aujourd'hui Jérémy Rimbaud est interné
dans cet hôpital psychiatrique de
Cadillac en Gironde
d'après les médecins le stress
post-traumatique aurait pu déclencher
une maladie plus lourde comme la
schizophrénie ce qui pourrait expliquer
les bouffées délirantes de Jérémy
la justice devra déterminer si le jeune
homme était responsable ou pas de ses
actes la nuit